this great big story was made possible
by wells fargo established 1852
re-established 2018.
[Music]
once a bountiful fish found in the deep
and rocky waters along the u.s south
atlantic coast and the gulf of mexico
overfishing now poses a serious threat
to their ability to reproduce
this is the snowy grouper
[Music]
the snowy grouper is named for the white
spots that speckle at scales
as the groupers grow these spots tend to
blend into the fish's natural brown
color
they will often eat crabs and small
squid that they swallow whole with their
large mouths
[Music]
snowy groupers all begin life as females
but as they age some become males
since the 1990s overfishing of juveniles
has affected populations because not
enough fish reach maturity to change sex
regulations were put in place but not
enough was done to slow the overfishing
of the species
the snowy grouper is now listed as
vulnerable and its populations continue
to decline
this is the snowy grouper
[Music]
you